Bruce is a shooting star with
magnificent he had that charisma
somewhere in it you could tell that this
was something was going to happen room
it wasn't happening canvas having a lot
of problems and a lot of difficulties
but the result was an unusual
performance and something that we can
compare to today Bruce gave up in
Hollywood he was just in despair he
couldn't get arrested went back to Hong
Kong with Raymond and did two pictures
that turned him into bigger than the
Beatles bigger than Elvis
and Freddie again said okay let's
finally do something with Bruce and we
did we came together we put together a
story we hired a young writer Michael
Allen who sorry he's not here tonight
and we came up with the screenplay for
Bruce we made it for three four hundred
thousand dollars and and they chipped in
in in foreign and we had something that
was very helpful for us we learned Paul
and I how to deal with other countries
and other people and they were excellent
Bob Klaus was just a grand director and
he had a wonderful visual sense of
thinking of things in like the mirrored
room and so he got in it and and Bruce
had given us a couple days off he was
away so bob was able to work out some
shots in there and it was very confusing
you couldn't stay in the mirrored room
for more than about 10 or 15 minutes and
when you were talking to somebody you
actually had to touch them because fred
is sitting right here but in the
mirrored room he wasn't he was over
there and so a lot of us kind of got
sick you know being in there too long
but but Bob came up with this great idea
to have the mirrored room and what we're
going to see ourselves all over this and
he said no we'll build this closet right
in the middle
but put mirrors on the outside of it and
put the camera inside and I met of
course of it Bruce Lee and the first
thing he did is touch here he was he was
iron high he says and he told me the
whole story how martial arts he told me
started in India but the monks needed
when they were going to countries right
they were been attacked by bandits and
they develop what I call the empty hands
form of self-defense and then that form
took this is five fifty five thousand
years ago said that that made a
evolution going from India to China I
got several other forms like kung fu and
then he went to Korea Shotokan quartic
window the winter to bid in Japan karate
and he said to me Bruce said I made
possible these changes I my techniques
are beyond I went I I go and beyond all
those techniques and I'm corporate the
best and I make it a different kind of
art a different kind of martial art so I
said oh then we have something in common
he said Lafayette yeah because the
classical music I started to come from
Europe in 2,000 years and I also went
beyond
with Lalo I said I wanna American music
but were the Chinese no I don't want to
Chinese I want to murder give me some
idea when I heard squirt was so great
I asked Bruce Lee why did he want to
meet me he says well I'm really happy he
said that you're going to write a music
because in Hong Kong in my dojo with Jim
when he practice martial arts he does it
with a record he used to do it with a
record of Mission Impossible